hello language enthusiasts today i'm
going to play the great language game
this idea is totally original i didn't
get this idea from pewdiepie or jack
spedici
no i had this idea long before them in
this game i'll hear some samples of
languages and i will have to guess what
languages they are at the end of the
game i'll get a score that reflects my
ability to guess the languages this is
kind of like the mystery languages
videos that i've made like these ones
right here
except that i'll be guessing the
languages instead of you so i'm ready to
fail and embarrass myself for your
entertainment let's go
alright here it is the great language
game i'm clicking play right now
get any worse
spanish
yes you got it okay that wasn't too hard
in
i really don't know
the sounds of finish that well but it
wasn't arabic it wasn't chinese it
wasn't vietnamese so by process of
elimination i know it's finished
you got it okay
okay so this is korean um
i don't speak korean but i hear korean a
fair bit living here in japan there are
a lot of korean visitors so i know a few
words and i know the sounds of korean
that's this one
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay this one is not vietnamese it's not
polish it's not korean so it's either
hindi or marathi
i'm not sure which one but i'm just
gonna go with
hindi because that's the only one i've
really heard i've heard marathi a little
bit but not really
hindi you got it okay
[Music]
sounds like norwegian to me
nice okay we heard that one before
well this sounds slavic to me but it
doesn't sound russian i don't know
specifically what the difference is but
i've never really
encountered much polish so i'm gonna say
polish because it sounds slavic but not
russian to me it could be wrong let's
see
whoops it was russian what do you know
okay well that was pretty easy because
i'm studying italian so
i hear it quite a lot
[Music]
okay so that one is portuguese so i
heard some romance vocabulary in there
that i recognized even though i've never
studied portuguese
you got it all right
okay i think this is vietnamese i hear
some tones in there and i've been to
vietnam and i've heard the language
before i think that's the one all these
others um none of these other ones have
tones as far as i know
here we go
[Music]
is not
[Music]
mr
[Music]
i don't know what this language here is
orcetic um
but it doesn't sound like any of the
others to me so i'm going to choose that
one
turkish
sorry
okay
i don't understand what the hell they're
saying so i think it's danish
you got it all right
okay
[Music]
turn that down
[Music]
hey give
i heard something about boko haram um it
doesn't sound like chinese doesn't sound
like norwegian or polish or spanish or
ukrainian i don't know about uzbek
but
because of the content i think it's
hausa
nice okay good
jack banke
technology
uh
um this sounds
definitely slavic to me but i'm not sure
if it's russian or ukrainian
um let's see
i'm gonna pick ukrainian kind of a crap
shoot
you got it yes all right
luck of the draw
now
another
[Music]
okay i think that one's swahili it
doesn't sound like any of the others and
something about the tomber sounded
swahili to me
yes all right
got it
[Applause]
mainly because
it doesn't sound like any of the others
and some of the pronunciation sounded
like it had russian influence and i know
that uzbekistan
has been influenced by russia so let's
say uzbek
yes all right i was right
i've only got one life left this is
nerve rattling
islamic states
i think this is swahili again
yes okay
some i heard some words that sounded
like they were borrowed from arabic and
they retained the arabic pronunciation
and i know that swahili has some arabic
words so that helped me to guess
okay that was french i know some french
[Music]
[Music]
i need to focus every time i get one
right i kind of relax and i think oh
okay now i can stop focusing but i need
to think about the next one okay wake up
paul wake up focus
do you like these
i think it's danish again because i
don't understand what they're talking
about
correct
whenever i have no idea what any of the
words are it's danish
that's because of the porridge in their
mouth
porridge in their throat
rosetta
well that sounds um slavic again to me
russian or this one ascetic which must
be a slavic language which one eenie
meenie miney mo catch a tiger by the toe
russian's more common go with that
you got it okay
i gotta look into this language ascetic
i don't know what it is i'll probably
get a lot of comments telling me what
you don't know what aesthetic is but
i don't
[Music]
care
god could the sound quality get any
worse come on let me find some clear
samples
[Music]
okay well i think it's aesthetic this
time
you got it okay
a
whoops okay i heard some words that
sounded like arabic to me so i thought
they were swahili words i guess hindi
has some words like that too
well there it is my score is
950.
see my knowledge of languages is not
perfect sometimes it's a guessing game
and i'm just looking for little pieces
that i can analyze and try to figure out
what's going on even if i'm not sure i
hope you enjoyed this video and i also
hope that you learned a thing or two why
don't you try the great language game
and leave your score in the comments
down below maybe you'll beat me be sure
to follow langfocus on facebook twitter
and instagram and once again thank you
to all of my patreon supporters
especially these magnificent people
right here on the screen for their
monthly pledges thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
you